Speaker 1: Let's go to Ray from North Carolina.
Ray, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 4: Thank you, David, for having me
on.
I was just asking, as someone who analyzes
news articles or watches like rallies for
MAGA candidates or Trump, for example, is
I notice that there has been a focus on trans
individuals and sports.
Yes.
What I've noticed is that people mainly focus
on male sport disciplines rather than the
female sport disciplines.
And it kind of boggles my mind that I think
maybe it could be it's an easier tactic to
go after trans females in women's disciplines.
So it kind of how does that entail?
Is it just an easier way for them to tear
apart this topic or.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So here's the deal.
You're bringing up a good question, which
is they love to talk about someone born biologically
male competing in women's weightlifting as
an example or women's swimming.
And there's a very specific reason for that.
This is basically a contrived issue.
So you take the entire think about these as
concentric circles.
Right.
Okay.
So you've got the biggest circle is.
Every issue that's out there.
Within that, you have issues affecting American
politics.
Within that, you have social issues.
Within that you have LGBTQ.
Within that you have trans issues within that
you have trans sports to make that interesting,
which again, is it's such a niche issue.
If you talk about, hey, you know what?
This person who was born biologically female
and identifies now as a man, they want to
try out for men's ice hockey.
All right.
Who cares?
Let them.
I mean, it's like it's not a compelling story.
It's not interesting.
Let them try out.
And most people would say if they're if they're
strong enough and physically big enough and
whatever, to make the team let them play in
the ice hockey, who cares?
So even within trans sports, you have to pick
essentially women's sports in which physical
size and strength makes a difference and only
focus on those.
There are states like in South Dakota where
there is not even a single instance of this
being an issue, as Scott Galloway told us
last week.
And they want to pass laws about it.
So you are exactly right.
They are picking what they believe to be the
most titillating based on the idea of this
six foot five individual born, biologically
male weightlifting against a five foot tall
woman or something like that.
Because they have to do that because most
of the examples we would all kind of go, I
don't know, it just seems fine.
Who really cares, you know?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I agree with that.
But I would think like if the narrative that
they could be kind of if somehow.
If an individual that was born or female in
one in a male sports, for example, one if
they themselves try to be outraged by it,
or maybe they would.
Speaker 1: I mean, that would be that would
be super interesting.
Like imagine a situation where a trans man
competed in weightlifting in the men's weightlifting
and won.
I don't know what they would say.
They probably would figure out a way to be
outraged.
I don't know.
They would say, oh, I don't know what the
performance enhancing drugs are.
I don't know what they would say.
It's an interesting question.
Speaker 4: Yes.
Something I've been looking into recently
for the past few years and definitely you've
taken notice to it.
With Trump saying no, no male in women's sports
in a sense that they only highlight that issue
in a lot of his rallies as he just exposes
that all the time.
Speaker 1: It is women and men sports they
seem to be fine with.
Speaker 4: Exactly.
And I'm I'm curious to see how this that builds
over time.
And thank you for your input on this.
It's really helped me out a little bit more.
Speaker 1: Ray, it's been a pleasure.
Ray from North Carolina, great to speak to
you.
We're going to take a very quick break, but
we're going right back to Discord and we're
going to hear from more people in a moment.
So don't go anywhere.